hi this is shaquille o'neal saying happy  holidays to everyone out there deck the  halls with balls of jolly la la la la la  la la  treat every day like christmas  number two  there's room for everyone except charles  barkley on the nice list number three  the best way to spread christmas cheer  is singing loud for all to hear  is the north pole closer to the moon or  california  there it is  [Music]  isn't it a little big  it's not fake it's just  full  dad that thing wouldn't fit in our yard  not going in our yard russ  it's going in our living room  oh ernie  help me out truck you're not fat you're  skinny  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  uh  are you not entertained  you are so weird  who is it  it's someone with no rings  [Music]  underdog put this on the t-shirt  charles wished she had this luxurious  hair and so does candy and sold us ernie  [Music]  la  [Music]